je ne suis qu'un homme parmi 7 milliards
d'autres
depuis près de 40 ans je photographie
notre planète pour essayer de comprendre
la terre sur laquelle je vis alors que
l'humanité progresse j'ai le sentiment
qu'on vit toujours dans un monde à deux
vitesses
plongez dans les inégalités déchiré par
les guerres on n'arrive toujours pas à
vivre ensemble aujourd'hui naïvement
comme un enfant pourrait le faire j'ai
envie de poser une question pourquoi
pourquoi de génération en génération
reproduite ont les mêmes erreurs
ce n'est pas dans les chiffres et les
statistiques je cherche une réponse est
dans l'homme pour moi qui photographient
la planète
c'est dans les visages les regards les
paroles que je vois aujourd'hui une
façon forte de plonger dans l'âme des
hommes
un proverbe dit que les yeux sont le
miroir de l'âme je le crois car il n'y a
rien de plus fort que quelqu'un qui te
regarde droit dans les yeux et quitte
ouvre son coeur
chaque rencontre de fait avancer
chaque histoire est unique en me
plongeant dans celle des autres
j'avais envie de comprendre avons nous
tous la même soif d'amour de liberté et
de reconnaissance dans un monde tiraillé
entre la tradition et la modernité nos
besoins immuable sont-ils partout les
mêmes
au fond qu'est ce qu'un être humain
aujourd'hui quel est le sens de sa vie
nos différences sont elles si grande ne
partageons pas plus de valeur qu'on ne
le croit et si oui pourquoi est-ce
toujours si difficile de se comprendre
j'ai envie de poser toutes les questions
de parler de l'humanité un pari fou
utopiste
avec mes équipes nous l'avons pris avec
beaucoup d'humilité
pendant deux ans nous avons parcouru 65
pays
filmer la nature et les espaces que
l'homme a créé fait plus de 2000
interview pour aller à la rencontre des
autres
ce dont on parle et surtout ceux dont on
ne parle jamais ce qui pour la première
fois raconté l'envi
j'ai voulu extraire les hommes de leur
environnement ne garder que les visages
et la parole
imaginez un film où la force des mots
résonnent sur la beauté du monde proposé
un voyage à travers des paysages mais
surtout à travers des histoires humaines
dans human il n'y a pas de commentaires
je laisser la parole brute pure en
mettant au coeur du film les maux de
l'humanité la pauvreté la guerre
l'immigration l'homophobie
j'ai fait des choix engagés politique
mais les hommes ont aussi parlé tout de
leur difficulté de grandir comme de
l'amour ou du bonheur et c'est la
richesse de toutes ces paroles humaines
qui fait le coeur de human